let's take some phone calls 617 830 for
750 is the number let's start it off
first caller today uh name and where
you're calling from the other support
mac award from Arlington Virginia Frank
our Catholic correspondent in the DC
area uh Frank what's going on I just
wanna let you know i'm i'm doing my
first volunteer event for Donald Trump
today you're volunteering for jumpers
I'm having a hard time hearing Frank I
don't know if that's my headphone or
what's going on yet but I you're not
actually a trump supporter though are
you oh no they're certain I'm gonna
lease with the dayroom here on the LOC
board okay uh that that is uh that that
is interesting and Lewis I'm still
having a really tough time hearing what
Frank is saying uh tell me once more
Frank exactly what you're doing up here
hold on oh boy now you're just cutting
in and out so I huh we're having a real
hard time with Frank today can you hear
me Frank let's start there yep you just
a better infinite better office the
veterans office he's saying right no no
assisted I'm in another office on my
office is inside that building I de Ruiz
the regional call back needed ask you
one question ok this is on history
Ronald Reagan's Alzheimer's do you know
it was diagnosed uh no I don't not
offhand spring of nineteen eighty one
right so that this goes to the idea that
it was actually sort of being covered up
during his presidency right yeah I heard
that from law it's about 20 years ago I
knew a med student at GW George watching
university hospital and she told me that
I she heard other party from the head of
psychiatry that it was diagnosed after
hit a ratings assassination attempt huh
ok well uh if true that uh that is
certainly quite a doozy I I don't know
this med student from GW from 20 years
ago so I can't personally speak to that
but it is there it has been speculated a
lot it has yeah and III don't think it
would change any of that um Republican
fetishism with uh with Reagan all right
Frank thank you very much want to take
it uh take it big under Byron R I don't
know whether a written that you guys
before not further one make sure you
knew that are circulated that
information the thom hartmann and no
other people well now we can set on air
so now I think we have certainly crossed
the Rubicon on it so to speak uh okay
Frank thank you very much appreciate the
call we will talk to you soon I'm sure
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home try-on to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses i personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try-on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trial dot-com / tdps I don't really like
going into glasses stores and trying on
glasses well the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home try-on I was able to pick
five pairs that i liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at-home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker calm /
tdps it costs nothing